The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[FELICE FRANKEL]
Christine Daniloff
is the art director
of the MIT homepage.
She's the person
responsible for getting up
these amazing images of
what's going on on the campus.
And do quite a turnaround
time, by the way.
It's amazing how she does it.
We're going to pick up in
the middle of a conversation
that I had with her.
I value her opinion
on so many things,
and I also value her friendship.
Here we go.
[FF] So they send
you stuff that they
think would work as an
image for the homepage.
[CHRISTINE DANILOFF]
Yes, they do, though -
[FF] I'm laughing because I
already know what you get!
[laughing]
[CD] They do.
They often like images
from the research.
And one example
I'm thinking about
was in one of the
labs at MIT, they
work on technology for
photographs-- imaging
technology.
And so it was this
very cool thing
where basically if
you took a photo, say,
with your smartphone
and it was blurry
and it was askew and all this,
the chip they were working on
actually corrected all of that.
All the information had
been gathered in the photo,
but it would automatically
correct this photo so that it
was almost like frame quality.
You could get this
really great photo.
[FF] So the algorithm-- they've
created an algorithm that
corrects for that.
[CD] Exactly.
So when I asked, are
there any images,
what they sent me was
an image of the chip.
OK, cool, and I think that's
valuable with the story.
Like here's the chip.
But the image I put together
was-- I started to think, OK,
we're MIT, and I know
that the local audience,
and I think the broad
audience too, loves "the dome"
and all this...
But I thought,
really what people
are going to get from
this, is that if you
have this image on a cell
phone and it's blurry
and it's not really
crisp, and then
you see this image-- the
same image-- clear, crisp,
framed on the wall.
[FF] Perfect.
[CD] That sort of gets the,
this is what it means to--
[FF] You're telling a story.
[CD] This is what
it means to my life.
When somebody looks at this
and is sort of like, OK,
technology, but why
does this matter to me?
Well, this is why
it matters to you.
And so that, I guess, is one
of the key questions I always
think about answering
in the image
is why it matters in our lives.
It's important work
that's being done,
but it's sometimes so
theoretical and so out there,
you don't even understand that
this algorithm will someday
might make it possible
for me to have
a robot that does my laundry.
That, people can get behind.
[FF] That's actually
very interesting.
So it's, "who is the audience?"
And that's something that
we talk about in the course
as well.
That says it.
[CD] I agree.
[FF] So let me just ask
you some technical things.
Let's say a researcher
does have an image that
is relevant to the science
and it is compelling enough.
Does it have to be a certain
file size, for example?
[CD] It does.
A high resolution is important
because low res images
are small images.
Even though I
primarily am designing
for digital display, which
is low resolution, to work
the image in high res
just creates a crisper,
sharper, more-beautiful image.
Plus, we're also able to use
that image on the new site
and offer it to press where,
when press picks up this stuff,
sometimes it's print.
It's often the Times
or Financial Times
or it's a magazine
and they want images
and they have to have
high res for print.
So high res is always best.
Keep your image as large as
you can when you send it out.
[FF] And you, as
the art director,
can zoom in and create
your own framing.
[CD] Absolutely.
You can crop things a certain
way to make something.
[FF] So does it matter if it's
JPEG or TIF or do you care?
[CD] It doesn't.
High res JPEGs are just fine.
[FF] I think so.
[CD] And I guess it depends.
Sometimes in my own
work or something,
a TIF is a high res file.
High res JPEGs-- if
it's just a flat image,
you're not working
with layers or anything
like that, a high res
JPEG is just fine.
[FF] So do you have some
examples of some images
that you've got that
didn't quite cut it?
[CD] Yes, I do.
[FF] I bet you do.
[CD] We get images-- I think
that overall my take is
that the scientists
and researchers,
they really want great
images for their stuff.
And I've had discussions with
many of them where we laugh.
It's like they're the scientists
and we're the image people,
and I want to make
sure that whatever
I do for them is accurate.
But we've had jokes sometimes,
well, you stick to the science,
I'll stick to the images.
[FF] Our hope with the
course, as I know you know,
is to raise the standards
of the researchers work
and to get them to pay
more attention to how
they create their photographs--
if it's photograph-able,
of course.
We're talking about material
that's photograph-able.
[CD] Absolutely.
Here is one example.
These were images
about carbon nanotubes
that can catch cancer cells.
So the images that
we got were sort
of the SEM of the nanotubes and
the proportions of the device.
But these are great
with the story
so people have a greater
understanding of what
they were doing in the lab.
But for something
that's supposed
to grab people's
attention and make
them understand what this will
do, it doesn't really work.
So I basically did
just that, and I
used photographs that came
from Center for Disease Control
images that were available
and able to be used.
But trying to think about how
do you get this across, and make
it visually compelling so
that people want to click
in and read about this?
[FF] So did you make this
nanotube as an illustration?
[CD] This, yes.
The nanotube is
actually an illustration
of a carbon nanotube.
And it's basically just carbon
structure in a tube form.
And sometimes, it's
an interpretation
of what's going on
in this research.
It's not promising anything
that they're not working toward,
but we make it clear that
this is a photo illustration.
This is not
something that came--
[FF] It's not a
documentary image.
[CD] No, it's a
photo illustration
of just what this
research is talking about.
[FF] So there is an
issue about scale
here-- that the nanotubes
are much, much smaller
than the red blood cells.
Are they red blood
cells or cancer cells?
[CD] No, the nanotube
is around a cancer cell,
and then there are red blood
cells because the whole idea is
that these nanotubes, I believe,
are catching these cells
in the bloodstream.
[FF] OK, so the relative
size of those things
in your illustration is
actually not correct,
and we've talked
about this before --
about how far can we go when we
make a depiction of something.
But for example,
many years ago-- you
might be too young
for this-- but they
used to show atoms and
molecular configurations,
and the atoms would show
the reflection of a window
to suggest some sort of
three-dimensionality.
Now, there's no way in
the world that an atom
can reflect a window because
an atom is a little bit smaller
than a window. [laughing]
Yeah, that's the way they
used to show that stuff.
So that's just a
depiction, but in a way,
there is an issue here
of showing something
that's actually not possible.
But you feel that
that's really OK?
[CD] Well, I think that
you need to make sure
that you're clear that this
is a photo illustration
or an illustration-- that
it's not actual imagery
from the research.
Like this wasn't
captured in the body.
And I guess part of
what I think about
is when you say that-- I'm
thinking in my head, well,
I guess I could've made
those blood cells huge,
where you wouldn't even
see the whole blood cell.
Just an arc of the red cell.
But the other thing
is that people
have to be able to see
it on the homepage.
So everything has to be
blown up so they can actually
see, what is this showing?
Sometimes you think if
you made everything,
it wouldn't read at
all at that size.
[FF] So the researchers
did not raise this issue?
[CD] No, and I think -
[FF] So it didn't
bother them at all.
[CD] Because it was clear
that it was an illustration.
And that's oftentimes
what we're tasked with --
is illustrating something
that we're trying to show
the components at work here.
But we don't have anything
in front of us to go by.
It's just sort of
showing that it's just
our interpretation
of what is going
to happen when these carbon
nanotubes can capture cancer
cells.
[FF] So for example,
when I color an SEM,
I always indicate somewhere
that I've colored the SEM.
Do you think that we as
journalists of science--
whatever we're going to
call ourselves today--
do you think that we
have a responsibility
to indicate, for example-- would
you have indicated this is not
scale or something like that?
Do you feel an obligation?
[CD] I think that science
illustration, absolutely.
But when I think
about what I do,
sometimes I think it's heavier
on the illustration side.
I wouldn't tell
anyone that this is
part of a scientific document.
Like I sometimes think it's like
art work to go with your story.
And I think that we do
have to be not falsely,
or give the suggestion--
knowingly give the suggestion--
this image is an accurate
image or a realistic depiction
of what's going on.
I think that is our
responsibility not to falsely
represent these images as
something that they're not.
But for a lot of these, I
look at them more as art
to accompany a story.
And I say "art"
because it's sort
of just my interpretation
of what's happening,
not accurate depictions.
[FF] It's not a documentary.
[CD] No.
And the other
thing about that, I
think to do things
accurately, as you said,
I have to crank these out.
I think sometimes about the
research I would have to do.
Like if someone
said to me can you
do a medical illustration for
me or a scientific illustration
accurately, that
takes much longer.
I think accuracy, at that
point, becomes critical
because this is supposed
to be an accurate
representation of exactly what
happens in a person's body when
this is happening or in this
chamber when my experiment is
going on.
That's a whole other thing.
I think if I were doing that,
I think I'd need more time.
[FF] Absolutely.
It's an ongoing conversation
that we have on campus.
How much are we permitted to
editorialize the depiction,
in a way.
[CD] No, I agree.
I think being honest
about what it is.
That's what I always feel.
I always try to be
honest about what it is
and then it gives you a little
bit of freedom to editorialize.
I think you really
depict the science
in a lot of these devices.
And I sort of am illustrating
what they could do
or how they might work.
[FF] Yes.
I'd love to see another
example of how something was--
[CD] Another example is
turning on a key enzyme
that blocks tumor formation.
And so I asked for an
image, and they sent me
a rendering of the enzyme.
And again, I know what will
work on the home page, what's
going to be compelling
in that format.
MIT home page has
elements on it,
and you have to
work with an image
that there's a
central image area
and there's navigation areas
that sit on top of the images.
So you're sort of
working with images
that will allow for all of that
to happen around it, but still
come through.
The image still pops
from all of this.
And so, I sort of know looking
at a rendering of an enzyme,
it doesn't grab you
on the homepage.
It just doesn't.
So this was about
blocking tumor formation.
And so for the homepage,
it's an image of tumor cells
that was absolutely beautiful.
You just want to look at that.
The detail is stunning
and that sort of thing.
[FF] So this is a scanning
electron micrograph
that's been colored?
[CD] Yes.
So we use micro-graphs
a lot from research.
Sometimes they're
absolutely gorgeous.
They are gorgeous.
I love them.
But if we have them
straight from the research,
if we color them or
add color to them,
we always try to state
that just so people are
aware of what's going on there.
And I think on the MIT homepage
and covers of these things,
your cover image
has to be visually--
it has to really pack a punch.
So sometimes the color,
things like that,
can really make a
difference, I've found.
[FF] So when a decision
is made, who else is
involved with deciding whether
it gets on the homepage or not?
[CD] Typically what
will happen is myself
and the director
of news sit down
and we go over
the stories, which
he's read all the stories.
He knows what is-- several
things come into play.
Variety-- we try to
have stories from across
the different schools at MIT.
So they're not all
biology or they're not
all computer science.
We try to keep a good mix of
stories coming out that are
going to be on the homepage.
If a story is really
incredible research
or for some reason very
important-- oftentimes,
the big journals, that
kind of helps you.
Like, well, if it's in
Science or Nature or some
of these really
big journals, you
know it's a significant story.
And the artwork.
Those two.
It's the artwork and the
significance of the research.
Because if we can't illustrate
it well or photograph,
it's not going to
work on the homepage.
On the home page--
you know, I know--
there's very little
text about the image.
It has to really-- there's
a short head, and a subhead,
and an image.
And if you can't make that image
really grab people's attention
and be something
to look at, then it
doesn't get on the homepage.
[FF] Simple as that.
[CD] It's as simple as
that because it really
is a visual page.
[FF] You have enough lead time?
Let's say you know an article--
an important article-- is
coming out and you also
know that they don't
have a visual to go with it.
Do you have enough lead time
to come up with something?
[CD] I do.
I've become comfortable in
the schedule that we have,
and the schedule in our
office with the news
director and myself,
we work well together.
I think he understands
that I need time.
And I will often say, sometimes
as a visual person you just
need-- and some of this stuff
is so, like I said, theoretical.
I will read whatever I
have about the research.
Sometimes it's just the writer's
paragraph pitch for the story.
And then I think about it.
I've got a week to work on this.
I know it's not coming
up till next week.
Sometimes it's just a day.
But these big ones--
[FF] You have time.
[CD] Yeah, it's like I need
some time-- like some hours--
to just think about massive
entanglement-- something
like that that you don't really
have a lot of visuals to go on.
This is something that is--
[FF] It's all mathematical.
[CD] It is.
And so how do you show
this in a way that's
beautiful and accurate?
And how do you make this
an important enough image
to put on the homepage?
[FF] I think this is
something that we're
trying to encourage our
students to think about,
to not only talk to your
colleagues or the experts
in your field, but to think
about ways to communicate
to the public.
And we're not training our
researchers to do that,
and I think that that's
one of the things
that we are discussing
in this course.
How do you come up with a
compelling image of your work
that is not only very
much about information,
but it's about wanting to
pay attention to the picture.
It's actually not easy.
[CD] No, I think it's a really
particular way of thinking.
And I think the
researchers are great.
They always, as I said,
will supply images,
and they always are
excited about-- some
of them very much
want to talk to you
about their ideas for
this and some of them
are very excited about it.
But some of them, you can
see they're scientists.
They do this incredible
work in the labs,
and they think about
communicating to their peers.
And the thing is, people
that can read the papers--
like the papers
that are submitted--
I often feel like it's such
a small percentage in a way
because some of this stuff, I
look at it and I'm just like,
wow - I don't --
[FF] I have no idea what
in the world this is.
[CD] Yes, I don't know
what's going on here,
and I know these equations
are really significant.
And I know in talking
about their work
and in proving what
they've discovered here
or the advances they've made,
that's absolutely necessary.
But to someone who
has a real interest,
say, in material science
but they're not a material
scientist, it's going to be
very hard to break that down
on their own.
So that's what we try to do.
I think the writers in our
office are great at that.
And you sometimes
grab people that
have no real--
like I wouldn't say
that I'm particularly
interested in materials science,
but that was such an
interesting image.
And safe bridges.
Whatever.
I read that story and,
wow, isn't that great.
[FF] It somehow
was related to me.
Somehow.
[CD] Right, and image
caught my attention.
[FF] Yeah, I think
this whole notion
of training the next
generation of researchers
to start talking to the public
is not incidental any longer.
And frankly, we
have the obligation
to talk to the public.
And as you and I talk about all
the time, it's through images.
[CD] Right, true.
[FF] That's one
very exciting way
to get somebody to at least ask
questions about your research.
So this is not
tangential anymore.
This should be part
of the research,
I think, from the
very beginning,
and you're doing an
amazing job doing this.
It still blows my mind
thinking about how
you can crank out these
stunning, stunning homepages.
It's just very exciting.
Do you have other people
that you work with?
Do you hire photographers
or video people sometimes?
[CD] We do.
I do hire.
Photographers are mostly what
I hire to get photographs
sometimes of the
researchers, sometimes
if there's a compelling set up
in the lab, which there are.
Or devices-- tiny
devices-- or something
that really you need a quality
photograph of to better
understand.
We absolutely hire
photographers all the time.
[FF] So there is a place for
photography in this world.
And what I've also noticed
very recently-- maybe
over the past few
months-- is that you
try to make moving images--
some sort of animation
piece to the still.
Am I right about that?
[CD] Yes.
[FF] So how do you
go about doing that?
[CD] I can think of a couple.
For example, when I mentioned
the massive entanglement,
that was totally illustrative,
but as the researcher explained
how the photon moved through
this mass of atoms that
were all entangled
and he described
the trajectory of the photon and
how it actually moved through.
So I replicated that
in this illustration
of what this sort of looks like
or what it could look like.
So he knew how the photon
actually went through this.
So I had that to work with
and I illustrated that.
And then in animating,
what I try to do
is sometimes I will use
various programs to animate.
And lately, my favorite
thing is working
in Photoshop making GIFs
in their video timeline
because they show
on every device.
So people can see
them on phones,
people can see them or
things like Flash-- you know,
if you're on an
iOS device, you're
looking at the still image
that I put behind it for you.
Or sometimes-- someone sent
me a beautiful micrograph
of a microfluidic
device, and cells
moved through this device.
So I had this beautiful
scan of this device
and the channel was very clear
how the cell moved through this
in the research-- what
they were able to do.
And so I just animated.
And basically it was
just a small sphere
but representing
the cell, and this
is how the cells are
moving through this device.
[FF] So you overlay
the animation?
[CD] Yes.
I overlay the animation
right on the image.
[FF] And do you think in
terms of how much time
the animation can last?
[CD] I do.
First, I think several things.
Sometimes I've had looping
animations on the homepage,
and I've found that it's more
of a local audience here at MIT,
but people leave the
homepage up all day
long because they will say
could there be an option
to stop the animation.
I have this up all day
and it keeps sort of-- I
keep thinking something's
happening over
here because I'm catching
the movement. [laughing]
So I've taken that into account.
If you're animating
something, I sort of feel
like if it's a subtle
animation-- I remember one
I did with a series
of photographs
actually for the
Collier Memorial.
And I could have done it
various ways in Photoshop,
but I did it with a series
of images and smooth fades
to make the candle flicker.
[FF] I remember that.
[CD] And I let that go all day.
[FF] Oh, it was so right.
It was just right.
[CD] Right, it just brings
that little bit of life
and thoughtful point of focus.
So things like that.
And that was all done
with photographs.
So the length of the animation.
If they're subtle, I am more
likely to just let them run--
loop them-- because I don't
think that they're distracting
in a way that some -
I get it.
If you're shooting particles
through a tube all day long,
I can get how somebody
sitting at their desk
could just be like, enough.
So I keep that in mind and try
to make it realistic enough
or make it a good viewing
experience, first--
so the timing is right
and it's sort of lending
something to the image.
Sometimes it's
really showing you
exactly how this device works.
Sometimes it's just
like with the photon
how this thing would have moved
through this mass of atoms.
So make sure it's offering
something more than a still
image maybe couldn't.
And then also, I think
about the length of it.
I want it to start fast enough
that somebody doesn't click
right off not realizing
that there's movement that's
going to happen.
But also, give them
just whether it's
a second, or a half a
second, or two seconds
to sort of catch
it when it starts,
but not have it last too long.
Because that's the other thing.
[FF] So it might be interesting
for us to hear if you could
take us through...
A starting point,
and then where do
you go from there to the
next, to the next step,
and what the final
animation or image becomes.
Can you take us
through an example?
[CD] Sure.
And I'll go back, again,
to this entanglement,
probably because I just
finished this one, actually.
So every step of it is
very fresh in my mind.
So as I mentioned, a
big story coming out
about the largest
number of atoms
that have ever been entangled at
one time with a single photon.
So that was the story.
And I knew we were going
to spotlight it because I
believe it's in Science.
It's coming out in Science.
It's a major thing.
So entanglement, you know?
So I went over to the right.
I said, this is sort
of what I'm thinking.
I said, I get entanglement.
It's two particles,
not joined together.
I'm thinking separated.
I'm thinking the
spotlight image area.
Particles representing
atoms on one side,
particles representing the
other atoms on another side.
And I had first thought about
multi-colored particles.
And blue will connect
with blue, and green,
and I'll animate a
ghostly line that
maybe shoots back and
forth between these just
showing that they're connected.
How does that sound?
And she said that it
wasn't really that.
It was like pairs of particles
entangled like that all
together, but that it was
a large bunch of atoms all
entangled together.
So it wasn't pairs.
It was maybe-- and to me, there
wasn't a particular number
I had to represent.
Just a large group
of atoms, and they
were all entangled together.
So those two rows or
two separate areas
of particles in my mind came
together as one big mass.
Great.
So I started drawing that.
I put a background in.
And I do look online to see how
are other people representing
entanglement?
What exists out there for this?
What do people see when
they think entanglement?
And you go on Google Images,
and it's all over the map.
So I thought, well, I think
all of these particles
together with some sort
of lines just representing
that they are
connected somehow--
a line that connects them all
together-- was not a bad way
to go here.
And so I have a graphics
person that works with me,
and I told him what I
think we should do here.
And I said, if you want
to think about that
and start working on
something like that.
So he did an image and he had
an oscillating wave of a photon
come in and shoot up.
Because that was another
big part of this research
is that they're entangled
with a single photon.
He showed me the image, and
he had spoken with the writer.
And he sent it off
to the researcher,
and the researcher came
back and said, you know,
I think that the emphasis
should be more on the atoms.
The photon is quite
large in here,
and it's really the
focus of the image.
And so he thought that
the atoms should really
be more the focus of the image.
So he talked to me about
this, and I said, well, look.
Let me show you what
I've been working on
for this because it's
going to be a spotlight,
and I do the homepages most
of the time-- probably 99%
of the time.
And I said, let me show you what
I'm thinking for the homepage.
And I showed him what
I'd drawn so far,
and I was thinking
of this line--
just this crazy, jumbled
line in the background,
but ghosted out.
It's sort of the
suggestion of connection
with these particles.
And so he asked if he could have
my Photoshop file to work with,
and I said, sure.
Why don't you work
with this and let
me see what you come up with.
So he basically did that--
took these particles
and did the line and all
this-- and showed it to me
and it was looking good.
And he sent it to the
researcher and the researcher
said he thought it was
probability that best
rendering of massive
entanglement he'd ever seen,
which is awesome.
If an MIT researcher--
like "wooo!"
So I had really thought
about animation for this one
because an image that
just has a lot of spheres
with a ghosted line,
it's cool looking,
but movement could mean a lot.
And so he said, do
you think-- and I
think at some
point animation was
mentioned to the researcher.
And he talked about showing this
photon come in and then go off
at a right angle.
The line that it
came in on is the way
that it moved in this research.
And so I thought, well, great.
That will be the
animation part about this.
Rather than me making
this ghosted line
like a bright thing shoot
around in these lines,
but to actually trace the
path that the photon took.
And so that's what it ended
up being was an animation.
I brought some of the
atoms up closer so
that there was different
scale and a different focus
in the atoms or a focal
point-- like this atom is
bigger than the other and
blurry in the background--
and then put the photon
through the mass of atoms.
[FF] And you used Photoshop?
[CD] I used Photoshop
for the entire thing.
[FF] Not Illustrator?
[CD] No, not Illustrator.
It was a simple
enough illustration
where you're
basically just working
with textures and
spheres with gradients.
And it was Photoshop.
And honestly, Photoshop I
work in more than Illustrator.
I do so much in Photoshop.
[FF] My experience
is that when I
have to make an image in
order to explain the science,
the process of making the image
clarifies the science for me.
[CD] Definitely.
Somebody said to me once,
when they asked what I did,
and I said I illustrate
the MIT homepage,
they said, you must be a
mile wide and an inch deep.
And it's sort of like
you start to learn
what the best batteries are
being made of these days.
[FF] A little bit
about tons of stuff.
[CD] A lot of stuff.
But I agree with you,
it really does help me
to understand the science more.
[FF] Absolutely.
And that's why we are hopefully
encouraging researchers
to think about
presenting your science.
Because the very nature of
thinking about the presentation
clarifies what you are
trying to communicate.
It's a very, very important
part of their education.
[CD] And people will
say-- sometimes I do
have people that
come up and say,
I remember that story
because I remember
there was an image that showed.
And so I feel that
gets it across.
People will remember a
story because of the image
that ran with it.
And they'll remember the
words, but they remember it
because the image
sparks the memory.
And that's pretty cool.
[FF] Thank you, Christine.
This is what this
course is all about.
It's been just great.
Thank you.
What a joy.
I'm so lucky to have
a pal on campus who
feels the same way as I
do and who, by the way,
does pretty unbelievable work.
[CD] Oh, thank you.
[FF] Thanks for coming.
[CD] Thank you.